on your own from the age of 15 reckless
aggressive and undisciplined this is a
rebellion isn't it IRA bail we have a
mission for you the major weapons test
is imminent we need to know what it is
and how to destroy it
is that clear yes what will you do
wouldn't it catch you
what will you do a Greek you
if you continue to fight
what will you become
hey youtubers is Charlie they finally
dropped the rogue one teaser trailer so
let's break it down
I've already been reading a lot of crazy
theories that people have about Jin's
character that's who this is Jin it's an
ensemble cast but just looking at the
trailer it does seem like she's the
protagonist like the REA of this story
and I like Forest Whitaker's quote where
he's like what's gonna happen if they
catch you what are you gonna turn into
if they break you a lot of people have
been asking like does this mean that she
turns into phasma just to be clear this
is set before the events of episode 4
they're stealing the plans for the very
first Death Star as Mon Mothma explains
you know everybody cheering in the
background hey Mon Mothma is back they
have a new weapon they're getting ready
to test it we want you to find out what
it is and what it can do as far as I
know the events of this movie just lead
into Episode four so it sounds more like
a standalone adventure we might see some
of these characters again but I don't
know if they have any sequels in mind
for them because there's a han Solo
spin-off movie they've been talking
about a Yoda spin-off movie that's what
they're calling these anthology films
all the different anthology films will
kind of jump around in the timeline on
their own so it's not like the next
anthology film even if it's a han Solo
Phil will pick up right after this movie
we learn a little bit about Jin's origin
story how she's kind of someone from the
streets she grew up just like Rey she
had to learn how to survive how to raise
herself she's a bit of a troublemaker in
a way that Rey is not I never really
thought from the pitch that Rey was a
troublemaker growing up both very
capable but the whole idea here is that
Jin is like the ideal candidate for
being a rebel forgery of Imperial
documents possession of stolen property
aggravated assault resisting arrest all
the things that mon mothma would be
looking for in her rebels we see her
walking around the base this does look
like the rebel base on Yavin 4 from the
original trilogy and if you really like
the tactile look that they went forward
with episode 7 this is so much more in
the style of the original trilogy it
almost looks like they traveled back in
time to film on those sets with those
props you really do have to give him a
high five for attention to details like
that there's even a little gonk droid in
the background here I think they put a
gonk droid somewhere in episode 7 but I
can't remember where it showed up just
one of those little Easter eggs that
they're probably gonna stick in every
single Star Wars film so always keep
your eyes peeled for GOG droids when
they say she's 15 that's actually
younger than Luke Skywalker was in
episode
for he was about 16 during the events in
that film and I can't remember exactly
how old Rey is but I think she's a
little bit older than that - here's a
fun detail the actors who's playing mon
mothma is the same actress who played a
younger version of the character in
Revenge of the Sith in the time since
that movie she's aged up and now looks
so much more appropriate for the older
version of mon mothma it's kind of like
a reverse version of ian mcdiarmid aging
up from the original trilogy as the
emperor - the prequels version of the
Emperor we don't know who Diego Luna is
playing but that might be because he's
playing someone from the original
trilogy is unless a lot of these rebel
characters die in this movie they'd
really only be a year or two older
during the timeline of the original
trilogy speaking of which stormtrooper
armor much more accurate to the original
trilogy the way they explained the force
awakens armor is that technology design
has just evolved in the thirty years
between the original trilogy and the new
films classic Star Destroyer design in a
very that's no moon type of scene the
shadow of the Death Star covering it
this is so beautiful we don't know who
this actor is playing but you might
recognize him from a couple recent
things he's been on Sherlock and he was
also on that Tom Hiddleston series the
night manager and then we get the reveal
of Ben Mendelsohn's Grand Admiral we
haven't seen many grand Admirals in the
series but he's wearing the classic
white uniforms he saw on the first Death
Star in the original film and it also
means that aside from Darth Vader he is
the big bad of the film he's kind of
like the Grand Moff Tarkin although you
don't really need to understand Imperial
politics to know that grandma is almost
as big as Grand Admiral it's two
different divisions of the Empire Ranma
Tarkin is more like the governor of
several systems Grand Admiral is just
one of the major leaders of the Imperial
fleet Forest Whitaker looking really
badass he's playing a bounty hunter his
monologue is the voice that you hear in
the trailer you know what will you
become if they take you this is a better
shot of that freaky-looking stormtrooper
that we saw in the teaser they haven't
revealed yet but they could be death
troopers they could be shadow troopers
there are many different kinds of
stormtroopers and I like the moisture
evaporator in the background very
evocative of that scene during Episode
four on luke's farm kind of makes you
wonder if they're gonna be on Tatooine
and there are some Jawas in this scene
here so we might actually see the planet
in the film and even if we're going to
see a version of darth vader i don't
know if we'll see some of the other
original trilogy characters like Luke
Skywalker like the big characters
finally get to see blind ninja Donnie
Yen this is gonna be super badass I know
a lot of people are wondering if he's
Kanan after the Star Wars rebels season
2 finale and I'm gonna go crazy if he
really does end up being a blind
force-sensitive just like Kanan he might
have been a Padawan during the purge but
he looks a lot younger than Kanan would
be because Star Wars rebels takes place
in between the prequels in this film
more Grand Admiral walking through the
wreckage and then we finally get the
reveal of I know a lot of you are
wondering if this is gonna be Darth
Vader but Darth Vader doesn't usually
wear a hood so this might be one of the
inquisitors because the crimson
stormtroopers are the Imperial Royal
Guard I'm wondering if we really will
see a version of the Emperor and Darth
Vader I don't think that they would do
the Emperor without doing Darth Vader
Forest Whitaker looks kind of like he's
sitting on the Millennium Falcon here
but I don't think that we're gonna see
that ship in the movie we don't know who
this actor is playing but his name is
Jiang wen just wearing some special
armor probably another character that's
helping the rebels even if he's not a
rebel himself 88 he's all over the place
just looking spectacular and then we
finally see Jin and Thai fighter pilot
armor so it looks like that's how
they're going to infiltrate the Death
Star there are a couple things that are
missing from this this is supposed to be
kind of like a team-up Ocean's eleven
movie where they steal the plans for the
Death Star we don't really see them
working as a team yet we met some of the
rebels we met some of the villains we
met some of the other people that will
be helping Jin out so it's really more
of a character trailer I think the next
trailer will be more of a story trailer
let me know which part of this is making
you freak out more really I'm most
excited about Felicity Jones and meeting
this Grand Admiral I'm really interested
to see if he's someone that showed up
during the EU but even though they kind
of got rid of the EU can and doesn't
mean that we won't see some familiar
characters because the expanded universe
did tell stories for a lot of characters
that appeared in the original trilogy
but we really haven't met that many
Grand Admirals in the history of the
Star Wars films giveaway time though
congratulations to the giveaway winner
Joe Douglas you win a gift certificate
for the Star Wars DVD the force awakens
DVD just be sure to private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details now that we
finally got some information about rogue
one we've seen some of the characters
let me know what you guys want me to do
for my next Star Wars bonus video and
don't forget there's an official Doctor
Strange trailer coming next week there's
going to be all kinds of new
Captain America stuff Marvel and Star
Wars are really dropping all kinds of
bombs in case you guys missed it in all
the craziness I did at Captain America
behind the scenes video you can click
here to watch that and you can click
here for all my Star Wars Episode 7
Easter eggs thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]